after President Trump's rally last night
in Phoenix Arizona it is being reported
that the entire mainstream media have
been admitted to Urgent Care for a
massive overdose of cough fa will report
as new details emerge plus Antonia
Okafor Amanda presto Giacomo and Jacob
arey joined the panel of deplorable zhh
to discuss ESPN's removing an Asian
sports reporter because his name is
Robert Lee the possible pardon of
Sheriff Joe Arpaio and Hillary's endless
whining that the American people
rejected her I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
I cannot possibly describe how much I
loved this rally last night I actually I
wasn't even watching it live I was at an
event at the Hollywood Bowl and a buddy
of mine in New York my friend bill we've
worked on a million campaigns together
good old Republican he texts me says I
hope you are smoking a cigar and
watching this right now it is
extraordinary it is Trump at the heights
of his powers it I know that all it
shows today are gonna be talking about
this I don't care I don't care if we're
all doing the same show I love it so
much there's actually too much good
stuff in it to talk about
there's the Joe Arpaio stuff there are
the protestors outside who just rioted
for no reason they didn't have any Nazis
to fight against it the this rally
actually reminded me a little bit of
president Trump's excellent speech he
gave in Rome do we have it in ancient
Rome
[Music]
[Applause]
I am that is exactly why I am here that
is the only reason I am here it was so
it was just a wonderful we had last
night here two nights ago rather his
speech about the Afghanistan policy was
very good it was sober it was
presidential he became humble for the
first time in many of our eyes he
acknowledged that he was going to change
directions he wasn't going to tell
people what his plans were he wasn't
gonna let the terrorists know he was
getting out and then he gives pure cough
eff a campaign today and he any
masterfully plays on the entertainment
of politics the retail politics not the
sort of stuff that they talk about on
CNN the sort of things that we talk
about and think tanks but just the stuff
of politics that make people tune in
that make people turn off reality TV and
watch the best reality TV show out there
so how did the media react I don't know
which was more fun watching the speech
or watching the reactions this was I so
I woke up this morning and I just took a
look at cnn.com and Washington Post com
now these are headlines just from above
the fold it's kinda hard to tell what
above the fold is now because we don't
have physical newspapers but these are
the main headlines on the website I'll
just run down them from CNN Chris ELISA
says Donald Trump's 57 most outrageous
quotes from the Arizona speech and in
that piece he says full of invective
victimhood
in fact free retellings of historical
events this is literally the first line
of his speech literally and then it's
just a bunch of whining about how Donald
Trump punch them in the face other
headlines on cnn.com this morning these
are all same morning right next to each
other
James clapper calls Trump speech
downright scary and disturbing Russian
ambassador downplays Trump relationship
I don't know why we're talking about
Russia again but they have to distract
from this rally somehow Hillary Clinton
my skin crawled when Trump stood behind
me I said what Trump hasn't stood behind
her since debates nine months ago but
they had they brought this back up to
try to get Trump's excellent speech out
of the news Melania Trump's thanks
Chelsea Clinton for defending Baron I
guess Donald didn't defend Baron Thank
You Chelsea Megan McCain slams man at
rally who called for her father's death
don't know the man was at the Trump
rally probably no but he doesn't really
matter the I'm not sure why we care what
Megan McCain thinks about this and white
what is this relevant why is this
relevant after Donald Trump has
addressed serious points in that rally
and actually made some news and then of
course the last one Trump can stay sane
for approximately 24 hours if this is
insane bring it on admit me to an asylum
Washington Post similar
similarly reports on their
above-the-fold headlines as Trump ranted
and rambled his crowds slowly thinned I
didn't see that I don't know why maybe
the cameras weren't good enough where I
was and lonely people I saw outside were
the rioting leftists I didn't see a lot
of trumps I did see a lot of Magha hats
walking around filing out of the
auditorium another one
Trump's vicious attack on the media
shows one thing clearly he's running
scared is that Marshall is that the
feeling you got at that rally he's
running scared yes maybe we were
watching different rallies then he is
vicious attack and the media he's
running scared doesn't seem to be
running to me seems like he's standing
his ground and punching these jerks in
the face quote James clapper questions
Trump's Fitness worries about his access
to nuclear codes I'm not worried
President Trump is deteriorating before
our very eyes dangerous 'i'm melting
there but they all of these headlines by
the way is that like biologically is
that what they mean that might be what
they're doing I think they're projecting
I think it's all psychological I think
all of these headlines are referring to
themselves they look at President Trump
and he is a mirror and they see
themselves deteriorating turning into
nothing another one Trump's attacks on
GOP senators are self-defeating I'm not
sure about that we haven't in all these
special elections that have come up
since the election the people who have a
supported president Trump and who
president Trump is supported have one
Republican of candidates for high office
and it seems to me that there's no
reason not to believe the president
Trump will have coattails in the future
Trump in Arizona shows just how unfit he
is I didn't see that Hillary Clinton
calls Donald Trump a creep saying her
skin crawl
during a debate nine months ago that
reporting on for absolutely no reason
but the best of all were none of those
headlines the best to halt with CNN's
Don Lemon but we have witnessed was a
total eclipse of the facts someone who
came out on stage and lied directly to
the American people and left things out
that he said in an attempt to rewrite
history especially when it comes to
Charlottesville he's unhinged it's
embarrassing and I don't mean for us the
media because he went after us but for
the country this is who we elected
President of the United States a man who
was so pitted Teddy that he has to go
after people who he deems to be his
enemy like an imaginary friend of a
six-year-old his speech was without
thought it was without reason it was
devoid of facts it was devoid of wisdom
there was no gravitas there was no
sanity there he was like a child blaming
a sibling on something else
his imaginary enemies you know his
imaginary enemy the media rewriting
history right now does Don Lemon have
any self-awareness whatsoever does done
he is saying we're not the media aren't
the enemy and he's giving this bizarre
he's saying President Trump is so
emotional he's unhinged listen to this
craziness from this just like a child
Don Lemon himself behaving like a child
before he gets to analysis clearly this
was ad libbed or was written during the
speech he couldn't have prepared it
beforehand and certainly didn't seem
prepared enough beforehand and this is
nothing new by the way it's not that the
CNN I think CNN wants to paint the
picture that they're reacting to
president Trump's totally uncalled-for
attacks let's take a trip down memory
lane and look at CNN's brian Stelter
president Trump's actions and inactions
in the wake of Charlotte's ville are
provoking some uncomfortable
conversations mostly off the air for
being honesty in discussions among
friends and family and debates on social
media people are questioning the
president's fitness but these
conversations are happening in newsrooms
and TV studios as well usually after the
microphones are off or after the stories
are filed after the papers been put to
bed
people's concerns and fears and
questions come out questions that often
feel out of bounds off limits too hot
for TV questions like these is the
President of the United States a racist
is he suffering from some kind of
illness is he fit for office I can't
believe we got brian Stelter on that hot
mic you know because these conversations
they're happening off the air they're
happening away from the microphones I
can't believe he's by the way he he's so
cogent and articulate for being off mic
totally off-the-cuff right they it's
it's almost beyond parody I don't know
how much more I can say about this guy
but the the self seriousness of it he's
saying look honestly they're happening
off-camera if they're happening off I
don't know how there's enough time in
the day because all of that which is on
camera are these same conversations but
to say the total obliviousness
to say that these things are happening
off-camera and then to spout all of this
conspiratorial nonsense into the camera
regular CNN John Nolte has for years
claiming that CNN is Isis and Hitler I
know that might be a little too I think
they're incompetent I think both Isis
and Hitler were much more competent than
CNN but his antipathy toward them is
perfectly understood and so James
Freeman at the Wall Street Journal
compiled a handful of examples that
refute a number of what the number of
things that CNN has said about this now
let's see if those conversations are off
the air first this comment the American
press is stronger than any demagogue but
President Trump's attacks do present
real challenges that's what today's
program is about poison that's what it
is it's a verbal form of poison meant to
affect your view of the media world
meant to harm news organizations
off the air again I guess this he's
gonna watch out for these hot mics brian
Stelter maybe this is his Amazon echo or
something is picking off of his uh
poison he calls it I'm glad that CNN is
is running away from hyperbole
now it isn't just this guy though it
isn't just these new guys Don Lemon and
brian Stelter here is Carl Bernstein
good old Carl Bernstein of Watergate
Fame having a sober discussion about
President Trump Carl I want to come to
you you're in Los Angeles this morning
you have been thinking about this
talking about Trump for months as a
neo-fascist I want you to tell me why
and and how you view this current moment
well it's it's a difficult term and the
word neo meaning new has a lot to do
with a new kind of fashion in our
culture dealing with an authoritarian
demagogic point of view nativist
anti-immigrant racism bigotry that he
appeals to I will never forgive Bob
Woodward for inflicting Carl Bernstein
on us I will never forgave Carl
Bernstein a little byline 50 years ago
40 years ago and now that he's inflicted
him on us forever to give his hysterical
and hackish points of view all over air
not just those guys how about a
presidential historian a scholar the
historian contributor to CNN Douglas
Brinkley help us out how do you convey
what's going on with the Trump White
House um it's an utter disarray and you
can't really compartmentalize everything
because it's all morph together as
Donald Trump unfit for command in my
opinion I mean you could go look at God
posit he's unfit for command I think so
let me be clear could you repeat that
again please I need you to say on air
again he's unfit for command now go back
to talking about the mobsters that you
just Michaels could you would repeat
that one more time oh yeah I'm sorry
brian Stelter and this historian guy
from some school in Texas says Donald
Trump is unfit for command
but imagine Airi enemy it's an imaginary
opponent I don't know what Donald Trump
he's attacking like a child as his
imaginary friend I don't know why he
thinks that the mainstream media are
just Democrat hacks out to get him now
Brinkley by the way is not just the
voice of the Academy he's not just the
voice of presidential history he's also
the voice of the American people she's
reminding us that one of Donald Trump's
curses
I think he's brought to Washington is
the shrinking of the power of the
presidency people used to really look up
to the executive branch and now will
everyday Donald Trump seems to be doing
something to make it look smaller and
they really used to look didn't you look
up to Barack Obama marshal during those
wonderful eight years usually look right
every day I next started to heard I was
looking up to him so much now this does
seem a little confusing to me because
beginning basically with the election of
Barack Obama certainly after the
Affordable Care Act Democrats started to
lose every single election they tried to
run so they lost a thousand seats in
state legislatures across the country
they lost a ton of governorships 24 out
of 32 Republican state legislature
states went to Republican governors they
lost the Congress they lost the Senate
they ultimately lost the presidency so
it seems to me that perhaps not all of
the American people looked up to that
past president seems to me that perhaps
Douglas Brinkley and CNN have no idea
what at least half of this country
thinks and they that's why this country
loads them and it's why they clearly
hold half at least half of this country
in utter disdain now this is this is my
favorite one of all this is my favorite
projection onto Donald Trump from these
Democrats and these hacks and these
mainstream media journalists but I
repeat myself there's been questions
about the 25th amendment to the
Constitution whether or not he should be
removed for medical reasons that Senator
corker is a real leader among
Republicans and it was very brave of him
to step out and really talk about the
fact that we have an incompetent
president and what does that mean for
our country the medical front look we
all know he is a neon billboard for you
know overt narcissism so brave such
cricket in the or thoracic Roger I can't
handle the bravery so I'm overwhelmed by
the courage now there are there are two
things in this that are pretty
astounding and this is coming from
Douglas Brinkley the I assume
psychiatrist since he's diagnosing the
President on air he or no he's just a
he's a hack historian at some college
and a and a poor journalist no he there
are two points here one he's talking
about narcissism Barack Obama wrote his
first memoir by the age of 30
three he wrote his second book about his
favorite subject by the age of 45 as far
as I can tell all Barack Obama has ever
written in his entire life or books
about himself beginning right after he
graduated college but on the other side
there are there is the media which
always talks about how irresponsible
Trump is being how how rash is being is
shooting from the hip and then they
bring on some historian to diagnose
Donald Trump with narcissistic
personality disorder on air and that's
fine I'm more than happy to imply that
Barack Obama is a narcissist I'll say it
explicitly but CNN is purporting to
present objective journalism and they
could not be further from that I have a
lot more respect for MSNBC because when
I go to MSNBC they're pretty upfront
with what they think
daily wire we're pretty upfront with
what we think but CNN it's just look at
that panel that they had my panel of
deplorable z' is much more balanced than
that CNN panel and we do not go for
balance that is not not our strength
here and so President Trump he stands up
to all of these guys he pokes them in
the eye he's a master at politics and
engaging this country I don't know that
he's a master of policy I don't know
that he's a master at White House
strategy I don't know that he
understands the Beltway lunch Club
people at all that he might not
understand any of them but he does get
politics and I think a lot of people
basically none of those people we've
seen on CNN understand it they don't
understand politics which is the art of
relating to people of talking to people
of hearing their concerns
it's the essentially human art it's what
separates us from the animals as
politics and president Trump
communicates to them directly he skips
by all of their filter and can engage
with the American people with that we
have got to bring on our panel of
deplorable --zz for this especially kff
a show we have Antonio Okafor
Amanda presto Giacomo and Jacob arey
thank you for coming on Antonio has the
mainstream media always been this crazy
or is Trump uniquely driving them insane
I think definitely that they have gone
to a different level with the Trump
administration
and the presidency I think that they
feel like now they are allowed to show
their crazy to the full extent so oh and
people will buy into it and they'll get
a lot of money for it so I think it
works for them it works for them too to
play into the hysteria of Trump and and
what he does and and I remember hearing
that broadcast my mom like I said is
very liberal and progressive and listens
to CNN every day and I remember on
Sunday what I know it's really hard I
really but and then really saying like
does Trump have a mental illness and let
me just be like what seriously we're in
this era when we're having this
conversation like I'm going to go to
praying Jesus after this I'm going to
church it's Sunday morning I don't want
to hear this nonsense but basically
that's what we're hearing all the time
and it's becoming normalized so we live
in an era where mental illnesses are
actual mental illnesses are completely
normalized and intricate Ritu suggests
otherwise
but yet when the president says we need
to enforce our laws that is signs that
he is lost his marbles Jacob why Arizona
why now right after the Afghanistan
speech a week after Charlottesville why
is he giving this campaign like rally in
Arizona well I was reading an article
earlier today and it said that it
reminded everyone that is really where
Trump's campaign took off he had
launched this campaign he was very low
in the polls and then he did this
rousing speech in Arizona and that is
what really propelled him into top-tier
status during the 2016 GOP primaries so
I really think that's why he did it he
remembers the city well and don't forget
that crowd that they all has mega
supporters that was an electric crowd
they were there to support him and one
thing I would like to note is Douglas
Brinkley he's not actually a Texan he
just plays one on TV he's actually from
Georgia I just wanted to point that out
that's an important distinction I was
there I was in Phoenix about three days
ago if I'd thought about it for five
seconds I would have stuck around for
the rally it is true a lot of people
they're carrying their guns
in there Maggie hats I saw it was it was
nice to be in a refreshingly sane part
of the country but your point is right
Jacob
he is replaying to his strengths here
he's clearly really good at these
rallies he's playing to his core
competency Amanda why is he so good in
this format he's pretty good at
Twitter's a mixed bag he can be great
and he can be pretty cringe-inducing at
times he gave that very solid
Afghanistan speech but he is electric in
these rallies they're clearly he's
better than anybody we've ever seen do
them why is he so good at them why are
these rallies the medium for Donald
Trump yeah I mean he's been doing this
his whole life I mean he was literally
on WWE I mean he's an entertainer
first and foremost so this kind of stuff
is just second nature to President Trump
and it really does just bolster his base
I'm sure there were a lot of people
within his base we're worried after
Bannen was outed because they felt like
there was no one there speaking to that
populist base and there really was no
difference he was talking about ripping
up NAFTA he's talking about the wall
shutting down the government if we don't
get the wall sheriff arpaio so I mean
this was just kind of reinvigorating his
base and like you said it I mean that
this is Trump this is second nature this
is why with no political experience he
made it to the White House he is an
entertainer he can captivate his
audience and he knows how to directly
speak to people like he's been doing his
whole life it certainly reinvigorated me
I was at the bole listening to the LA
Philharmonic do the planets and as I'm
listening to just the bringer of war and
destruction I'm reading all these Trump
tweets and I couldn't possibly be more
reinvigorated all right are you a story
I'm sorry go ahead though there was one
point where I mean I saw it in a tweet
from a reporter but I didn't see all of
it but I guess apparently Trump said
that CNN is not even airing this rally
and it was live on CNN who saw those
lights are going off those camera lights
are turning off so our next story we
have to talk about is it was brought to
my attention by Antonia Okafor it is the
best story I've read in a long time but
if you don't subscribe to The Daily wire
then you can't see it you have to go
over right now to The Daily wire duck
thank you to everyone who's already
subscribed you can go watch the rest of
the show live it's $10 a month $100 a
year you get me you get Andrew Clavin
you get the Ben Shapiro show but forget
all of that all of that is worth so much
less than this the finest compartment
for beverages known to man
that has ever graced the face of the
earth being leftist tears tumbler it
keeps your leftist ears hot or cold and
depends on the time of year
sometimes in winter I like them hot with
a little marshmallows on top in the
summer I prefer iced leftist ears you
can keep either in here they are always
salty and delicious go over right now to
the daily wire comm you will get all of
those things we'll be right back
you know first thing in the morning I
wake up and typically my first thought
is Antonia Okafor so I go to Twitter and
I'm so glad that I did because Antonia
brought a story to my attention ESPN has
confirmed that it pulled Asian American
sportscaster Robert Lee off of the
University of Virginia's home opener
football game quote this is them copping
to it simply because of the coincidence
of his name Amanda is there any role for
parody left in the world or has ESPN
transcended that smashed at and and left
us all babbling idiots we were just
going back and forth and we didn't we
didn't know if it was real she's like
should I even go forward with this I'm
like no no no no it can't be real and
then it ended up you know she got an
email from ESPN that it was real I mean
we didn't even believe it basically this
guy has a you know a traditionally Asian
last name so he was punished because it
resembled a Confederate General the you
know I think they wanted to prevent this
from becoming a meme and having people
talk about Robert Lee but as a result if
you get a chance to go on Twitter today
the visual memes that people have made
oh this agen reporters face on robert e
lee's body riding a flag he just
absolutely tremendous thank you ESPN
Jacob that network ESPN has struggled
for years with declining viewership as
it makes its coverage of sports
somehow political I don't know how they
do it but they've managed to do it is
this the nail in the coffin is this
thing finally done forever oh yeah I
think so what's what's worse is ESPN was
called out from doing this months ago
right and they said you know what forget
you forget our fans we are going to
double down on this and now they're
political correctness has just gone too
far this is ridiculous I think I think
this is the the the middle of the end
for ESPN I can't watch it anymore I'm
not that I don't love watching sports by
do love watching baseball and some more
centers
times can't watch it it's just their
coverage has become beyond the pale
weathers the MLB network that's true
that's what I subscribe to now so I can
watch baseball Antonia it's not a
serious point is this evidence that
we're living in two different Americas
the it's hard by the way it's hard to
make asian robert e lee serious but
we'll try we'll do what has to show are
these two different Americas there was
clearly a board meeting somebody had
meetings and memos to discuss whether
they need to pull a guy because his name
is Robert Lee it seems totally insane to
I think most Americans but clearly some
people think this is a serious issue
worth doing has the culture split so
much the common culture evaporated so
much that we're in these irreconcilable
cultural camps well I feel first that
you know as a as a reward that people
who subscribes that I should get some
non fake news credibility to New York
Times right and actually talk about the
state and say the actual statement where
it says we collectively made the
decision like right there collectively
I'm just like okay well we already know
what the issue is is collectivist this
is ESPN collectively made the decision
yes yes see and collectively made the
decision and then it says I began what
was it in that moment it felt right to
all parties it's a shame that this is
even a topic of conversation it's a
shame that this is even a topic yeah it
is a shame hey look we all agree yes yes
we all agree listen to your own words
please yeah I think it definitely is
this to I found about out about it
yesterday
I too was looking at the Twittersphere
and I was like no this there's no way
and then finding out quickly that it's
true and just weeping we were country I
don't know I've made a testament to me
that I'm like okay by here CNN or
somebody else saying and York Times even
now I'm just like okay big news whatever
but now I'm like okay
ESPN oh man I just feel like that is
more than middle America right it used
to be now but it's really a testament to
where
everything is going it's just you know
I'm I'm it's yeah it's a sad thing it's
a sad reality now that they feel that
this is going to be an issue for people
that people are so offended now and so
therefore they're gonna just not take
that risk and you know what maybe people
would have been offended that's the
problem - people might have been
offended that's true you know it's a
great point it's it's not a totally
unrealistic fear that there would be
some backlash to it I'm sorry Amanda go
ahead yeah no I'm just saying it just
shows how insulated they are was there
not one moderate or conservative person
around to be like hey this is totally
insane there was not one voice of reason
I mean we like at Google when we saw
they were just exercising people who
dared to you know break through
diversity code that just we're all on
these little enclaves and there's no
diversity of thought and this is what
conservatives and classical liberals
have been fighting for and this is just
an example of that where there's there
is no other thought I mean really there
was not even a moderate to say this is
totally insane they just yeah this
sounds right I mean this is the andrew
pleavin theory of newsroom's
which is not the way to fix newsrooms he
says is not to get a bunch of moderates
or a bunch of people who've done a
political opinions it's to get at least
one or two conservatives in there just
so that when people do things like that
and they start talking about things that
are so fringy and absurd the
conservative can say hey guys maybe we
should put the brakes on this for a
second I think we at least need to bill
I'm sorry go ahead
no just Clay Travis the reporter who
broke this was on Tucker Carlson and he
made the point that only 4% of sports
reporters voted for President Trump I
mean it's it's monolithic again it's
just it's crazy
I'm sure 94% of Sports viewers voted for
Trump but there is a difference between
the media and the base I think we what
we need to do is build a statue to the
sportscaster Robert Lee if anybody puts
that together i will donate I'll be the
first check that gets mailed out now we
need to talk about I'm sorry go ahead
before we talk about it that off Antonio
before I say I think it's important also
to know that this is a part-time job for
this man he is a payroll services
he works full-time at a payroll services
company in Albany but also I thought
they told him that instead of covering
this game he's gonna instead be covering
next month the University of
Pittsburgh's game which their mascot is
the Panthers so I'm just thinking why
would a Black Panthers be upset with you
are saying ahead of the curve exactly
exactly September 2nd I promise you that
will be the next outrage well come back
next month I'm sure we'll be talking
about it last night
president Trump hinted that America's
toughest Sheriff Joe Arpaio might
receive a pardon for a conviction he had
it's a little complicated but he was
convicted of being in contempt of court
because he kept rounding up illegal
immigrants basically but there was a
worry that he was racially profiling the
Barack Obama's DOJ called him out on
this and so anyway there is a chance
that President Trump will pardon him
let's see the clip
I could just stare at that image all day
here the video was Sheriff Joe convicted
for doing his job
that's what
[Applause]
he should have had a jury but you know
what I'll make a prediction I think he's
gonna be just fine okay but but I won't
do it tonight because I don't want to
cause any controversy is that okay
I can't you can't help but love the guy
Jacob is there is there any actual
worried that this flouts the rule of law
or or is Trump right it was Arpaio
prosecuted for doing his job personally
I think Arpaio was prosecuted for doing
his job but honestly President Barack
Obama commuted the sentence of a traitor
so the left doesn't need to be throwing
stones at this you know those who live
in glass houses should not throw stones
so I'm for him pardoning Sheriff Arpaio
and Dinesh D'Souza president Trump if
you're listening so you know that's just
my that's just my take on it I think
that Sheriff Arpaio was doing his job he
was watching out for the safety of his
citizens and his constituents and he was
prosecuted by the left Antonia the
allegations are going to fly I cannot
like you I can see ahead a few news
cycles I can see where the fake news
media are going to go with this
allegations are gonna fly that he is
excusing racial profiling the president
Trump is making an excuse to round up
Hispanic people of all legalities and
this is coming one week after
charlottesville do you think that this
is a bad idea to do it so close to that
heated event or is this just more
evidence that the Trump train has no
brakes
haha the Trump train has no brakes yeah
I think to be honest especially watching
that video was just a testament that
Trump does not care I think after this
second time he did his speech after
startzville just like no you know what I
am NOT gonna win on this issue ever so
I'm just gonna be well I'm just gonna
say what's on my mind I'm just gonna
rally rally up these people who are you
know Pro the sheriff and you know talk
about it on on
on the news and I'm sure people are
gonna be upset about it I don't but you
know what he has he has you know how was
Diddley on this but he basically has
been able to say anything that really
would have been would anybody else been
okay
and have the media spin it to something
that they wanted to be so I don't think
he's ever gonna win with that so he
might as well just be who he is and a
lot of Republicans out there in past
presidential nominees would say well I
didn't mean this I didn't say that and
no they would react to the mainstream
media coverage and Trump just seems to
say forget about it you're never gonna
love me and I'm gonna move on now Amanda
all of this signals that President Trump
actually intends to fulfill his campaign
promise of reducing illegal immigration
and deporting criminals and building the
wall do we think that that is actually
going to happen over the last month or
so it has become increasingly unlikely
what are the odds that we actually build
the wall it's going to happen I think
people like Ann Coulter has basically to
keep putting pressure on President Trump
I mean it's nice to have a rally but
they need to see some actual action but
but that's sad we've already had look
they could spit like 50% of a decrease
of illegal crossings so like this has
been said before President Trump kind of
is a wall a virtual wall so he's right
yeah it really has really it's done a
lot to kind of curb that so but of
course we want a physical wall so you
know future administrations cannot just
you know revoke these rules or what have
you so I think it's I think for sure
we'll have more headway on immigration
because it does play so well with the
base and that was one of the main issues
that got him to the presidency so I
think would be foolish if he didn't so
you know I know Bannon is gone but still
I think it wouldn't make sense for me to
go ahead with this and I don't see why
he wouldn't so I kind of feel like it'll
happen I agree there is this sense I'm
not sure that I even really care about
the wall itself I just wanted him to
build it I want him to build it for the
credibility of the borders of the United
States
and to shut up the mainstream media and
the lefties who suggest that controlling
your own immigration policy is somehow
bigoted or wrong
I really want him this is true of a lot
of aspects of his presidency I want him
to do them even if I don't care
especially about the actual policies
themselves well yeah speaking of the
presidency
speaking of the presidency we have to
move on to someone who is not president
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton has a
new book coming out titled what happened
Hillary Rodham Clinton now when you look
at the cover it's a the title is what
happened and the byline is Hillary
Rodham Clinton but I think that might as
well just all be the title here is a
quote she just released it today for
some reason probably to distract from
this rally quote my skin crawled it was
one of those moments where you wish you
could hit pause and ask everyone
watching well what would you do
she's referring to debating Trump when
he was absolutely crushing her quote do
you stay calm keep smiling and carry on
as if he weren't repeatedly invading
your space or do you turn look him in
the eye and say loudly and clearly back
up you creep get away from me I know you
love to intimidate women but you can't
intimidate me so back up isn't that like
when someone insults you and then three
hours later you think of a good comeback
that's like Hillary Clinton except for
ten months later it's really to quote a
great man sad Antonia Democrats famously
cannot take responsibility when they
lose elections they never get over it we
see it with Al Gore we see with Dukakis
obviously we see with Hillary Clinton
why is that Republicans seem to move on
just fine but Democrats seem to just
harp on it for the rest of their lives
oh sorry I didn't hear that
you were mesmerized you're mesmerized by
Hillary Clinton's beautiful words losing
elections yeah so I know it's not only
just that you know is it you know ten
months later that you know she thinks
it's a good comeback but then she like
hire someone else probably to write that
comeback for her and then they don't do
that great of a job either
that's base
quickly white Hilliard's you know come
back is so yeah absolutely I just think
it I mean another thing we Republicans
do a good job about about that I mean
Mitt Romney had a freaking great Netflix
movie that came out after his after him
losing and if anything a lot of people
were like why did not come out
beforehand people probably would have
voted for you more but this is not gonna
be the same thing for Hillary it's gonna
be like just stop like get over it
know your comebacks work this book okay
great you can buy your fourth home or
something you make myself feel broke but
you can buy your fourth home now
yeah I mean that's basically it and you
don't know people like this when it out
but I think it's the Russians I think
they're messing with your Skype
connection they're messing with your
life what Jacob yes Hillary's future
thank you are these attacks are they are
they part of a Democrat strategy what is
this book what happened and all of the
things Trump is a creep he intimidates
women yada yada yada
is this part of some larger Democrat
strategy to defeat him in 2020 or is it
just Hillary Clinton throwing a temper
tantrum and proving with each and every
word that she's utterly unfit to hold
the office of the presidency well I
think it's a combination of both it's
basically the Democrats are running on
we're not the party of Trump and also
Hillary Clinton has always been
vindictive so she's going to just to say
the least
you know I'm being polite she's always
been vindictive so she's saying oh she's
a creep she forgets that she's married
to a creep and she's kind of a creeper
herself I mean as a lawyer she defended
a child rapist and again basically
victim shames this the poor the poor
victim in the case so I think it's just
sour grapes she's just throwing a temper
tantrum as you said and that's all there
is to this and her last book didn't sell
well her husband's book sold better
ironically enough but so I think this
book will just go nowhere for because
everyone knows what happens the DNC
nominated Hillary Clinton that's what
happened well
you say that Hillary Clinton is
vindictive are you insinuating that the
Clintons keep suiciding people all
around them
I can either confirm confirm nor deny
that we'll have to talk about that honey
later episode all right thank you to my
wonderful panel of deplorable --zz for
being here Amanda presto Giacomo antonia
okafor and jacob arey now it is time for
my smart glasses in the final thought if
all you read were the Democrat hacks in
the mainstream news media you would have
good reason to think that President
Trump is not only Hitler but mekka
Hitler you would become more convinced
with each story to that effect and these
purportedly objective purportedly
journalistic outlets each run dozens per
day but when you watch the man
unfiltered it becomes clear that he is
not at all like the left-wing water
carriers at virtually every major news
outlet desperately wish to portray him
he has an essentially economic agenda a
vision of American greatness that a
rising tide lifts all ships and that
this policy agenda must be coupled with
a spirit of patriotism that overwhelms
superficial categories that separate and
divide the American people it's an
important message and one that Democrat
operatives who play journalists on TV
are desperately trying to pervert and
suppress now more than ever
Republicans must come together with a
clear vision and a single strategy quote
despite the constant negative press
coffe FA
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolan show come back tomorrow
and we'll do it all again
[Music]
[Music]